the upcoming midterm elections and the
newly drawn congressional lines tensions
are rising in many states over the way
these districts have been determined by
state legislatures one example georgia's
14th district which was redrawn to
include a greater piece of suburban
atlanta while maintaining a large
portion of the state's rural northwest
as robert costa reports it's caused
alarm from some voters about their new
representation
powder springs georgia a majority black
community north of atlanta has long been
represented by a black democrat in
congress but no more they have basically
cracked the community strength that we
have here what they've done is take a
predominantly african-american area and
combined it up with north georgia and so
to dilute our strength now powder
springs is set to be part of georgia's
14th district represented by
congresswoman taylor green a trump ally
who has been criticized by democrats and
some republicans for expressing
conspiratorial views the upheaval was
caused by the state's gop-controlled
legislature which redrew the lines of
the state's political map this year
following the census we've got to put
america first and get this country right
back on track greene has said she
welcomes the addition to her district
i'm excited to have them in my district
and we're happy to help and i hope
people give us a call many democrats say
the new maps here and nationwide carved
by republican state houses are unfair
their voices will be diluted their power
in this process simply washed away the
alarm about how redistricting efforts
could give the gop more power extends to
capitol hill i would say they give
racial advantage in the guys
given partisan advantage they are taking
race into account but not
to be fair not to be inclusive
but to do just the opposite house
majority whip james clyburn is the
highest ranking black lawmaker in
congress what i think is taking place
today is the beginning of a process
where will it end but many republicans
disagree and say it's politics at play
not racism
this congressional map
drawn in back rooms
by party bosses in annapolis
makes a mockery of our democracy
democrats are facing their own questions
about how they have drawn the lines in
blue states i think it's a false alarm
former new york gop congressman john
faso who has been advising republicans
on redistricting
they
overreached they attempted to
gerrymander
the republican party out of existence
for now anger and apprehension over who
is representing who in washington just
weeks ahead of the midterm elections i
don't like it because i don't think
she'll give us the right representation
for all the people
and her demonstrations have shown that
she's not for all the people there was
no logical way that margie telegram
could come into cobb county unless you
gerrymandered the district you have no
choice but to believe that race played a
part in it
ultimately the supreme court could
decide just how far state legislatures
can go with redistricting later this
year the court will hear a case about
how state courts can weigh in about how
districts are drawn
for cbs saturday morning robert costa
atlanta